[Music]
let's go to amy in portland oregon hey
amy what's going on
hi thanks for taking my call of course
thank you for calling the show would be
really lame it's caller show would be
really lame if people like you didn't
call in so what's up how can we help
well i'm calling because um i've been
married for
over 15 years to a really wonderful man
he's kind he's supportive can i stop can
i just stop you for some reason
it doesn't work the opposite it doesn't
it doesn't work when husbands call about
their wives
when a wife calls about her husband and
preps it with like 10 different positive
adjectives i know something's coming
so i've been married 15 years he's
wonderful and great and what
and what
just dropped the other shoe
yeah he i'm
i am enabling him to continue to work
part-time
to be generally lazy
um to not take care of me and his family
um
and to spend time on youtube and
listening to podcasts and and getting
into so into politics and things that
matter but
um i just can't do that anymore and i'm
just wondering how did we move forward
because i'm ready to
do big drastic things that make him
understand this isn't working anymore um
i don't
i don't feel like we have ground for a
divorce or anything like that but i mean
sometimes i think like do we
separate our money now or do i move out
so we can see that he is dependent on my
money to
keep doing these things and he needs to
work and so i'm just i'm not really sure
how to go forward with this
whoa
there's so much here number one
you started the call with i'm enabling
him
and so
i want to
what's the right thing
i love that you are looking for the
things that you can control
i don't know that you're enabling him
because you're not his mom
and i know that over the last 15 years
he has been way more like a child to you
than your partner and your lover and
your
um
best friend right you've been his mom
for a while is that fair yeah
yeah so in that sense i guess you've
enabled him but he's a grown man
right and so you have
yeah he's a grown man via age so maybe
instead of enabling him you have duct
taped and
nailed and and screwed this family
together you've held it
down
while you've got a um loser of a husband
in the next room playing video games or
like learning the nest conspiracy theory
right
i don't know if that's enabling as much
as you filled in all the gaps because
you're trying to keep your family
together do you have little kids
we do we have two
daughters six and eight who are even
aware of this i mean they ask me like
how come you know how come we don't do
that chocolate and i'm just like because
i'm the only one working full-time and
they're like what does that mean and
exactly they're getting an extraordinary
picture of what
a uh
what a partner looks like in marriage
right
what a great image for them to carry
around when they start dating oh this is
what um
geez you're gonna get me yeah you're
gonna get me all fired up yeah yeah
oh man okay so
you've talked to him about this before
what's he say
why won't he get a job why would he work
only turn the stupid computer off
um he he always says i understand i i
know that you're frustrated
and
he he has
typically had one or two part-time jobs
um and sometimes they equal about you
know a full-time amount of work but just
with colon and other things like lack of
ambition and initiative to keep his
non-profit going um it's kind of fizzled
out god what non-profit is it
is this some church-related thing
yeah it's a christian ministry and
that's what's hard because it's not no
listen it's not
so sick
of people using
non-profit christian ministries
to do nothing
to just sit there be like well i'm just
waiting for it's it's it's an insult to
it's an insult to christian faith it's
an insult to people who are out working
14 hours a day to help feed their
families and help feed their communities
and their neighbors it's an
embarrassment
it's shameful
okay and and
yet in theory these things are great
right in theory they're gonna help but
his is not helping anybody
is it
not currently no it's not it's not it's
not helping any
girl it pisses me off those things drive
me crazy no i just want to i just want
to start go get a job
go get a job and then take money and
give it to home do that right
um i just so god's called me to quit
everything and just um for my wife to
work full-time while i sit here and surf
the internet and
oh my
gosh it makes me rage out
so when you say you're about to do
drastic things what are you gonna do
well um about six months ago i told them
that i was going to leave if we didn't
get a part-time job were you being
serious or were you threatening
no i was serious i had told him i had
shown him the places i was looking into
moving into why haven't you left yeah
i had figured out a budget i don't think
you're actually going to leave i think
you're threatening him
like well you know that um tom at work
thinks i'm pretty what do you think i i
think that's what you're doing
hmm
i feel like i was pretty laid out but i
mean but you're not going yeah
well now i'm thinking um
about just
taking my money that comes in from my
job and just putting it into a different
account no don't do that listen if you
do that number one
you are modeling for your daughters
and what a
strong powerful woman looks like
and you would be choosing to disconnect
your marriage even further under the
same roof
don't do that right don't
don't heal cancer by shooting yourself
in the foot
okay does that make sense yeah so
i thought i mean i've had people from
our church talk to him um
i don't i don't know what to do at this
point
yes you do
listen when you've sat down with him
and said
i'm taking the internet out of this
house
you have to get a job
what does he say uh i know baby i know
i'm just uh i'm working what did he say
he he went out and got a part-time job
that's bullcrap why won't he go get jobs
oh yeah um because yeah there's ministry
or whatever i mean to the point where i
said i'm ready for this it's not a
ministry it's a waste of freaking time
it's not um it's
you cannot wrap up
a bum
it right with like a little jesus ribbon
on it you can't do that
well i'm really working no it's over
close it tell him this that he is
choosing a part-time
failure
over you and your daughters
yeah
because that's what he's doing
because he's also
he's putting a picture not only of a
lazy partner
but he's
creating a
your daughters are growing up with a
exhausted resentful mom
because they pick up on your eye rolls
they pick up on your
they pick up on your
um
just you're gritting your teeth they're
absorbing all of that
yeah and it's becoming the air they
breathe it's becoming normal
yeah and you amy deserve more than that
am i telling you to divorce your husband
no but he's cheating on you with a
failing nonprofit
he's cheating on you with the internet
and i'd be willing to i don't have a
great car it's a piece of crap to be
honest with you but i'd bet it
um
that he's got some sort of other
relationships on that computer too
whether it's pornography whether it is
his little political conspiracy theory
buddies
right whatever it is
he's got an alt universe that he lives
in
and my guess is he is probably depressed
beyond all depressed
yes
and he is in a s he is sitting in ash
and he doesn't know how to get up
and i can talk to him your friends can
talk to him people from church can talk
to him a counselor can talk to him but
until he decides
i want my life to be better for myself
for my wife for my daughters until he
can put the mouse down and quit clicking
he's putting you in a position to have
to choose the life of your daughters
to choose your life
that make sense
no it makes perfect sense so i am not
telling you to leave your i'm not
telling you to leave your husband okay i
hate divorce i'm high on marriage i love
it
but he's drowning your family
and i don't think this is just me i
don't think you've been clear with him
i think you have tried your best to be a
peacekeeper
is that fair maybe tell me if i'm wrong
tell me i'm wrong no it no you're right
i i mean i'm always trying to help him
find the next solution
and give a idea of you know just a
band-aid trying to always apply a new
band-aid that's right
so there's something else going on in
his life
that he's either hiding from you or he's
drowning in
and it's time for all of that to come
into the light and here's my guess amy
and you
tell me if i'm right
my guess is there's other people that
you're going to with your challenges or
your frustrations or you're have
you're on a fast track to finding
another life too if you haven't already
i mean i just talked to a counselor
i tried it you know i try to do it right
or i talk to
women from my church you know i try to i
try to do it right i mean
but it's hard
yeah
and somebody else
you know i've spoken openly with him
whenever people are men that have given
paid attention to me and i said you need
to know that this is how affairs get
started because someone is dissatisfied
in marriage and then someone else starts
giving them attention and so you need to
do a better job in this marriage
and he's and he's been very receptive
and said you know i'm sorry and things
get better temporarily and
and so we're just always on this it gets
a little bit better it goes back normal
you all are at it
you're drowning okay that's like you
find a hole in your boat and he puts a
piece of duct tape over it and you're
drowning
yeah so all you got to rip the router
out of your house
uh-huh i thought about that
disconnect the internet today disconnect
it
and tell him in my house and our house
we're not gonna have internet we're
gonna have each other
and you tell them i made an appointment
at such and such family therapist you're
coming and if you choose not to come
you're sending a very clear signal that
you think this marriage is over
yeah
and there cannot be ambiguity there
cannot be any more peacekeeping there
cannot be any more protecting his
feelings
because you are drowning
like when you're a lifeguard and
somebody's drowning they will and they
they will hit you they will grab you
they'll drown you too they will tell you
to elbow them or punch them to get them
to stop so that you can get both of you
to shore okay i'm not telling you to
elbow or punch your you punch him what
i'm telling you is you're trying to stay
wrapped up with somebody who's drowning
you
right yeah okay so all the lights come
on tonight
all of them
or you let him know tomorrow i'm taking
a half day of work the kids are going to
such and such and we are having this
conversation and if you've got somebody
that you trust
a counselor you can have this
conversation in front of them great
it may be good for you to go to your
counselor and say i'm at my or what
moment
because i will not let my daughters grow
up in this i will not be held hostage by
a
waste of time failing
non-profit that prohibits my husband
from getting a job or from being a
present father or for putting down
stupid political crap and being present
in our family
i will not be second rate to a youtube
channel and a whatever whatever whatever
and by the way
nonprofits are awesome nonprofit
ministries are awesome
but they don't take precedence over your
family they don't take precedence over
eating and they don't take precedence
over
um
math
they have to work
people have to want to be a part of
these things that's what
that's a whole other thing
amy i'm sorry
i'm sorry
but the dancing and the peacemaking is
over now we're in it now you're in it
lights are on you're going to get
somebody to sit with you you're going to
walk through here's the things that are
going to be different in my home you're
going to ask your husband to be a part
of it and you're going to let him know
clearly and unequivocally not with
threats not with well you know bill
thinks i'm pretty none of that crap none
of that well i've got another apartment
if you don't none of that
those games are over
you got two little girls watching this
whole thing play out absorbing every
second of it they deserve better than
this you deserve better than this he
deserves better than this
he's got to get help for his whatever
addictions he's got which he does he's
got to get out of these other
communities which he is and he's got to
get help for his depression
and somebody who loves them is going to
flip all the lights on and say done
somebody says done
so i want you to let me know how that
goes
let me know how it goes okay and it's
gonna be hard and it may not go great
all right or this may be
finally
finally right
thank you so much for that calling